what's popping variant it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
but listen up gang after these two
episodes of an insanely good Loki season
2 I've only got one thing to say I do
not trust Ora Boris at all listen I love
actor kiho Kuan as much as the next
human being with a soul and I know that
OB is a nice man to everyone that he
meets and I was legitimately happy to
see him get the recognition that he
deserved from his number one fan Casey
in episode 2 but nonetheless that man or
Boris is a man with a motive and I
believe that or Boris could very well be
the true main villain of the entire
season as the main reason why a lot of
this chaos is happening so let's dive
into why this could be the case together
my nerd babies all right so I know that
you guys are wondering why I'm accusing
a man who was effectively the tva's
version of Winnie the Pooh of High Time
Crimes and Multiverse misdemeanors and
you know what I don't blame you so far
in the series it very much appears that
OB is just a happy guy who is excited to
help the new friends that he's made into
trying to save the TVA from destruction
but nonetheless I'm here to tell you
today on this day that OB is truly an OP
that man's an OP OB is the True Villain
of the Season that is seeking revenge
against all the employees who have
wronged him for eons especially one
Mobius M Mobius and there's a couple of
reasons why I believe OB is the big bad
of the season and it basically boils
down to his tragic past as well as the
symbolic meaning behind Ora boris's name
and I also have a feeling that all of
this will lead to OB being revealed as a
much anticipated Marvel villain in
Disguise but first let us talk about
ob's past because that is where I
believe the core of his secretly
malicious motivations lie now in episode
one when Loki and Mobius first meet Obi
we learned that OB is the only employee
in the tva's research and advancement
department and because of this he has
spent his entire existence fixing all
the broken equipment and or bananas of
the TVA non-stop for countless Millennia
even telling Loki and mob that he
doesn't even sleep for fear of falling
behind on his incessant workload this my
nerd babies is exactly why I believe OB
is up to no good because OB has been
treated like absolute garbage for so
damn long and is still being treated
like garbage by the TVA even to this day
throughout episode 2 despite everyone in
the TVA already knowing that they were
all variants kidnapped to be used as
tools by a Madman at the end of time
everyone is still treating OB like a
slave of a repair man with both Hunter
B15 and Casey only invoking Obie's name
when they need something from him even
Mobius and Loki are still taking
advantage of his kindness by treating
him as some type of repairing machine or
something no one ever comes and visits
OB without needing something from him
directly and no one ever says thank you
and it's been that way for OB for eons
this all being said I have a strong
feeling that this disgruntled repair man
has been using the Mayhem of the
chaotically branching timeline in order
for all the coor workers who ignored him
to suffer and hopefully die especially
Mobius who apparently was the last
living being to visit OB after taking
the wrong floor in an elevator 400 years
prior to the events of Loki season 2
which is why I believe that OB purposely
sent Mobius out to be exposed to the
skin peeling radiation of the Sacred
timeline in a cracked containment suit
and it's also why I believe that a
malicious obes sent Loki on a mission to
prune himself secretly hoping that their
Reliance on each other would cause their
own demises because for some reason Loki
was worthy of being a friend to Mobius
despite being a war criminal of a rogue
variant and OB wasn't I mean hell Mobius
couldn't even remember ob's name when he
came to see him again when OB thought
about Mobius all the time after that
last visit because he felt like they
made a meaningful friendship connection
but apparently he was wrong because you
see the main reason why I believe that
both seasons of Loki exist is to show
the audience the effects of loneliness
on living beings and how isolation
itself is all one really needs to be led
down a nefarious path season 1 was all
about this theme of loneliness as it
explored the lives of both Loki and
Sylvie and how their lives of solitude
forged them into a man that can't be
trusted and a woman who doesn't trust
anyone and that season ended with both
of those two lonely lokis meeting the
loneliest man of all time and
discovering just how much he who remains
his own isolation had driven that Kang
Varian insane enough to send the entire
Multiverse into chaos in that very same
vein OB will continue this very
important theme in season 2 by being a
silent disgruntled employee purely
driven by the pain of his Millennia of
solitude and slavery for people who
barely even care that he's alive and I
believe that this is secretly part of
the reason why OB doesn't help mobus and
Loki when they come back to him for help
with X5 10ad in episode 2 instead of
taking like two seconds to help M and
Loki with their own mission to save the
TVA OB merely brushes them off and
basically tells them that he's too busy
with trying to fix the time Loom to help
them them when he is clearly doing
something mysterious with that temporal
Aura extractor that he gave Loki and
Mobius in episode one all Obi does is
just give them a copy of his guide book
and then tells them to figure it out
which to me felt like a major bit of
passive aggression from a man who is fed
up that no one wants to know how to
solve their own problems like he
literally made a guide book for that
purpose and nobody reads it and later
when a well- read Casey recommends a way
to OB to bypass the blast door protocol
OB stops him by just telling him that it
wouldn't work in that Casey should just
trust him because he's the one who wrote
the TVA guide book I think that that was
absolute this in my opinion is
just OB weaponizing and monopolizing his
intelligence because OB knows that
without he who remains being in the
picture anymore that he is now the
person who knows the most about how the
TVA stays afloat and this being the case
OB is now effectively the most powerful
person in the Multiverse because he's
the only person in the TVA outside of
Casey that isn't severely crippled by
ignorance like Obie literally went from
a forgotten zero to the tva's number one
hero overnight and I feel like OB is
kind of loving and hating that right now
because while I'm sure that OB
appreciates being remembered and getting
new visitors who now see his value OB
didn't magically become valuable because
the sacret timeline broke down like OB
has always been the tva's greatest MVP
outside of Mis minutes but nobody cared
all they cared about was getting their
equipment fixed by the guy downstairs
without a single thank you and
especially without taking the time and
efforts to read the guy book that he
specifically wrote so his fellow
co-workers could actually help
themselves because their willful
ignorance to how anything in the TVA
works is what caused OB to not be able
to sleep or be social for an ungodly
amount of time and now OB is using their
ignorance against them as Revenge
because isn't it funny how OB is the
only person who remembers Loki visiting
him in the past when everyone else
seemingly has no memory of Loki's
extremely memorable car crash of an
entry like I have a strong hunch that OB
knows exactly what is going on with Loki
but is using Mobius and Loki's own
ignorance against them by basically just
agreeing with their flawed logic as to
what is actually going on like I believe
OB condescendingly does here wait is he
talking to you in the past and you're
just now remembering it wow that makes
perfect sense there's no flaw in that
logic people that OB wants the approval
of are also the people that OB has grown
to resent the most which is why I
believe that this current situation is
very Bittersweet for Obie it seems to me
like OB is trying to finally get the
recognition that he deserves before
wiping out every single person that has
made his life a living hell possibly
even secretly wanting to use the
temporal extractor that he's fiddling
with to extract new variants from the
sacred timeline to take their place
possibly even all variants of himself
scattered throughout the Multiverse
because after eons of talking to just
himself I can definitely see OB wanting
to do what Kang did and build a council
of OB variants to run the TVA with
perfect Precision when when everyone is
gone because if every person in the TVA
knows how to fix everything then there
is no need for a research and
advancement Department OB would have an
entire TVA filled with the only person
that he can rely on himself but speaking
of self-reliance another core reason why
I believe that Ora borus is going to be
the main villain of the series has got
to do with the symbolism surrounding his
name and how that symbolism is tied to
the overall plot and themes of season 2
for those of you who don't know Obie's
name Ora Boris is actually based on a
real piece of iconography of the same
name that depicts a snake or Dragon
figure consuming its own tail for energy
and sustenance and because of this the
oror syil has become synonymous with the
concept of self-reliance across
different cultures and mythologies
something that OB knows all too well
however what's most interesting to me is
that in Norse mythology the Ora Boris is
linked to the concept of the world
serpent also known as yman Gander
according to Norse culture yman Gander
was a serpent who encircled the entire
planet with its tail in its mouth very
similarly to how the sacred timeline
encircles the TVA and the Citadel at the
end of time with its own tail in its
mouth a mouth that the TVA refers to as
the temporal Loom this all being said I
believe that the sacred timeline of the
Loki series is supposed to be Marvel
studios's adaptation of yorman Gander
the great Ora borus of Norse mythology
with the temporal Loom head of the mcu's
world serpent currently choking on its
own tail of increasingly branching
universes it's a giant Ora Boris this
entire season of Loki seems to be
revolved around Ora Boris the man being
charged to fix the cosmic Ora Boris that
is the sacred timeline and since North
mythology has the world serpent yorman
Gander being one of the main Bringers of
the end of all things during Ragnarok
this season being centered around a
sacred timeline glitch leading to the
potential end of the entire Multiverse
is also thematically appropriate as well
in a show about the Norse god Loki but
the main point here is that there is an
overall or Boris theme in the series
that appears to indicate that the
character of OB is a lot more important
than the series has been initially
leading on and that OB could potentially
end up becoming a major force in the
Multiverse Saga to come by the end of
this Loki season in fact I have a
feeling that OB could actually end up
being revealed as the king variant Mr
Griffin who made his debut in 2015's all
new all different Avengers number one as
a lot of you may already know Mr Griffin
was a version of Kang that was stranded
in the modern Century after a glitch in
the time stream split him apart into
multiple different variants of himself
with Mr Griffin being one of those new
variant identities that was born and
while he was stranded in the modern time
Mr Griffin would end up founding the
company known as Kang Enterprises and
purchasing Stark Tower to serve as Kang
Enterprises new base of operations all
while secretly spending every waking
moment of his life trying to find a way
out of the 21st century with all of his
company's resources even telling the
Avengers that he was willing to not
sleep for 2,000 years to make that dream
a reality but not only this Mr Griffin
was also an extremely vindictive person
even going as far as forcing Miss Marvel
to watch her mom get hit by a bus and
die just because he felt like it and
because Miss Marvel messed with him in
the past but one of the most interesting
things of note about Mr Griffin is that
he had a special ability to time slip
other things and other people at will
pretty much any other element outside of
himself now this all being said
considering that this season started
with Loki time slipping all over the
place OB secretly being Mr Griffin and
using his time shifting Powers could
potentially explain that strange
phenomenon that happened to Loki I could
definitely see OB being the direct cause
of Loki's time slipping just so Mobius
could come back down to RNA to see him
again because he knew that breaking a
temp pad or a computer would not be
enough for Mobius to make the trip
himself he had to break Mobius his new
best friend a best friend that OB is
jealous of it seems like he just wanted
them both to come down to see him so he
could send them off to die as Revenge
but anyways not only do the characters
of Mr Griffin and OB both wear green
ties and refuse to sleep but also Obie
secretly being Mr Griffin would also
make sense considering that we saw Kang
tower appear in the void in the last
season of Loki teasing Mr Griffin's
coming influence to the MCU through his
purchase of Avengers Tower in the 616
timeline Branch so it would make perfect
sense for Marvel to continue that thread
that they teased with that Easter egg
last season through the origin of Mr
Griffin this season but whether or not
OB is actually a basement dwelling Mr
Griffin in Waiting my main point here is
that there is more to Ora Boris than
meets the eye in Loki season 2 and that
his tragic TVA history could cause him
to be revealed as The Secret Snake that
he truly is I'm watching you OB I'm
watching you but anyways thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertainment on Twitter
if you guys want to see me tweet some
weird I'm also on Instagram if you
guys want to see me post some really fun
memes but most importantly do not for
forget to subscribe to heavy spoilers
today because we always got some really
fun stuff for you guys on the regular
and my boy Paul has the best breakdowns
in the business let's be real and hey if
you got a free second don't forget to
drop a thumbs up because that really
helps out the channel but again thank
you guys so much for watching I
appreciate your time and your love I'll
see you guys later bye